[موسيقى]
بلد سادوس وليست بلده لان سدوس بن شيبان
وابن ذهل من بكر بن ال ابناء عم لبني
حنيفه سميت هذه البلده باسمه هذه البلده
واربه في التاريخ قبل سدوس نفسه
والدليل على ذلك القصر الذي وجد فيها ونسب
الى النبي سليمان عليه السلام لكنه للاسف
ازيل ثم ازيل بعده
المسله او الاسطوانه او العمود الاسطوانه
الضخمه الى قبل 150 سنه كانت موجوده وتكلم
عنها لويسبيلي ازيلت لانه كان بعض الاجانب
يزورونها هكذا يقال قاموا اهل البلده
فهدموها واخذوا صخورها بنوا فيها ابار
وبنوا اكيد ان الصخور موجوده الان هذه هي
اللي كان منحوته نحت دقيق مبني من هذه
المسله العظيمه اذا سدوس
كانت اصلا على درب التجاره درب البخور
القديم الذي اسس في الجزيره العربيه عده
طرق خارج من الحجر اليمامه مرورا بالدرعيه
بالعيينه
بسدوس وهي ايضا ممر اصبحت ممر لاحقا لذلك
اكثر الرحاله الذين جو للرياض ياتون ومن
القصيم اذا اتيامن منهم احد باتجاه الغرب
يمرون على سدوس ثم على العيينه ثم على
الدرعيه ثم على حجر اليمامه الى حتى الى
الفاو المرورا بالافلاج مرورا بمناطق
طويله فهذه سدوس بلد تاريخي عظيم يعود
لسنين طويله لكن للاسف ازاله هذين
المعلمين لولا لويس بلي لم نعرف عنهما شيء
يقال انها واحه ثريه للاستقرار وسط
الجزيره العربيه
كانت محططه تجاره واستراحه على طريق
البخور وكان لها دور في حروب اليمامه من
سادوس تخرج علماء وشعراء وقاده وفرسان هي
واحه مياه عذبه ومزارع وحصون وقصور اما
تاريخها المنسي فلا بد من البحث عنه بين
حروف وسطور نقوش عثر عليها بالحرف الثمودي
ادل كثيره تدل على اقدميه بلد سادوس وهي
النقوش الثموديه الكثيره كم نقش موجود في
سادوس وايضا لا نستطيع ان نلم كل النقوش
الموجوده ايضا في
العيانه وفي وادي حنيفه كل يوم العرض
اليمامه كله
في سدوس عثرت من ثلاثين عام على 22 نقش في
السلسله الشماليه لسادوس
ونقش ورسوم في جنوب سادوس في قاره عصيدان
ونقوش في اسفل الوادي وهذا النقش اللي نحن
نقف بجانبه الان عثر عليه الاستاذ محمد
الحمود وقراه
الدكتور بروفيسور سليمان الذيب
وقراءته هي
لد لد بلد لد ابن زد ابن زيد ابن زيد او
زيد يعني علم اسم علم اسم رجل اذا النقوش
هذه لا بد من توثيقها وتدل او درست يعني
نتمنى انها تدرس وانه يحافظ عليها لانها
تتعرض العوامل تعريه بشريه وطبيعيه وتدل
ان الثموديين استوطنوا هذه المنطقه
الشيطان قديم وقبل قدوم سدوس ابن شيبان
ابن بهل وبكر بن وائل وبني حنيف هذا قبلهم
مئات المئات من السنين قدرها الدكتور
الذيب
بثلاثمائه الى سبع مئه سنه قبل الميلاد
اي نعم وهي كتابات ثموديه متوسطه او خط
التمودي المتوسط
[موسيقى]
حكمته وبلاغه كلماته ابدل حكم الخليفه
العباسي المعتصم بالاعدام الى عفوا وتقدير
وهديه ثمينه انه تميم ابن جميل السدوسي هو
الذي كان لسانه يزن مظهره الوسيم ابهر
الخليفه بابياته فاستبدل الاخير السيف
بابتسامه وعفى عن السدوسي ذلك الرجل
الشجاع لم يكن بين رقبته وحد السيف الا
زمن نطق فيه ابياته المؤثره وبعد العفو
اهداه المعتصم ولايه على شاطئ الفرات
ومعها 50 الف دينار طيب يا ابو عبد الله
بمنك من سدوس ما معنى سادوس
سادوس اسم علم سادوس ابن شيبان ابن دهل من
بكر ابن وائل
سدوس قيل انه الثوب الاخضر سندس وسادوس
مترادفات
وسدوس بفتح السين بعضهم ينطقها سدس من طي
من هم قاتل عنتره بن شداد هذا طائي
الاسد الرهيس
نعم غير سدوس هذه بالضم وهذه بالفتح
سكنوا القريه
اسمها القريه فسكنها بين السدس قبل
الاسلام بما يقارب 200 عام في نفس الفتره
اللي سكن ابناء عمهم بني حنيفه وادي العرض
او فيما بعد عرفه بوادي حنيفه سكنوا قبل
الاسلام ب 200 عام
وتكاثروا فيه وحينما جاء الاسلام ذهب وفد
من بني سدوس الى الرسول صلى الله عليه في
المدينه في السنه التاسعه للهجره
وروى عبد الله بن الاسود السدوسي الصحابي
الجليل الذي هاجر فيما بعد الى المدينه
المنوره قال اخذنا معنى الى الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم تمر من البرود برود بني
عمير نخل المعروف في سدوس في تلك الفتره
فنثرناه على نطع امام الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم قال اي التمر هذا قلنا الجذاميه
قال نعم التمر
ونعم الحديقه الحديقه خرج منها هذا او
الجنه خرج منها هذا او بما معناه
فبني سادوس
فيما بعد حينما جاءت الرده
ارتد بعضهم وذكرنا
تمامه ودوره معهم في في تلك وكانت من ضمن
القريه من ضمن البلدان التي لم تدخل في
صلح خالد بن الوليد رضي الله عنه
وكثيرا من كثير من الاعلام في في العراق
سدوسيون في اللغه العربيه وعلوم الشريعه
قال نختط البصره في هذا الخربه او البصيره
فاقترح على عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنهما
ان يبني فيها البصره فبناها في سنه 22
هجريها السدوسي معروف وعاصر الخليل يوم
علماء كثار رغم انه صغيره لنا اخرج الناس
انا ترجمت الكثير منهم في الكتاب عن سادوس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لم يسلم احد من لسانه اللاذع وهجائه
السليط مع ذلك ففي ابياته احيانا مديح
وحكمه يقول مؤرخون انه اول من بدا بكتابه
الشعر القصصي الحطيئه الشاعر الذي سجن
اكثر من مره بسبب حده لسانه يعرف انه عبسي
الا ان علاقته وثيقه جدا ببلد سادوس وهي
علاقه نسب وارث ونخيل
[موسيقى]
الشاعر الفحل العربي الحطيئه افضل واجمل
من وصف الكرم العربي ايضا من سادوس
نعم هو سادوسي
ذكر هو انه جاء على بني عبس سنين جذب
فذهبوا الى عوف السدوسي وكان من اثرياء
سدوس فقال
والده العبسي لوالدته
تطهري واستبضعي من عوف السدوسي لان حصل
بينهم جفوف فيبغى يرضيه ويكون له يد عليه
ففعلت ما امرها به وحملت بالحطيئه من عوف
السادوسي فجاءت الامطار على عاده العرب
وذهبوا فولدت الحطيئه نشا الحطيئه في بني
عبس عبسي الى ان
عيره احد
اترابه بانك عبد بني سادوس
ثم مات ابوه فاشارت عليه زوجته امه مليكه
اشارت عليه ان يذهب الى اخوته في سدوس
ويطلب ارثه من والده الغني فذهب الى هناك
وطلب منهم الارث فقالوا نحن اهل مزارع هذه
النخيل السحوق الطوال لك منها عدد كذا
نخلات وسميت نخيلات امه مليكه
طبعا هو بدوي ولا يحسن رقي النخل
وتاديره وتشويكه وصرامه فطلب المال ورفضوا
ان يعطونه المال
فغضب منهم ورجع وانتسب الى عبس وله اصلا
من بني سادوس واورد ذلك في ابيات شهيره
معروفه هذا الكلام اللي تقوله مهم في
الادب العربي لانه لا نعرف يعني الخلاف
على نسب
الحطيئه قائم لكن الان انت وصفت وصف دقيق
ونخل الامه لك موجود يا نعم
في سادوس نعم ولكن كان الزواج في الجاهليه
على عده اوجه منها الزواج اللي ذكرنا
ومنها الزواج اللي نعرفه الان وهو غير
نعرف الان هو اللي ثبته الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم واقره وغيره نهى عنه محرم
في طريقه الطويله من الكويت الى الرياض
توقف الكولونيل للرحاله
في بلد سادوس فادهشه فيها قصر وعمود صخوره
متناسقه وتصميمه فريد فطلب من مرافقه رسم
العمود ذلك الرسم هو الوثيقه الوحيده التي
وصلتنا حتى اليوم عن البناء الاسطواني
الشاهق بيلي وكثر بعده وثقوا تاريخ سدوس
الثري جدا مقارنه بمساحتها
[موسيقى]
الرحاله اللي جو السدوس كم عددهم وما
اهميته وليش اهتموا بسدوه والله اول من
ذكر
سدوس محمد بن اسحاق الحربي وذكر العمود
الموجوده في سادوس وقال عنها بناء
قديم عجيب خراب مبني من صخر كله خراب
وبقيت القصبه ما نعرف شكل القصبه جاء عدد
من الرحاله وذكرها عدد من علماء المنازل
والديار الى ان جاء لويس بلي في سنه 1281
في شهر مارس
1865 في طريقه من الكويت لمقابله الامام
فيصل بن تركي في الرياض فمكث في سدود
ثلاثه ايام تكلم عن بقايا القصر ورسم لنا
العمود رسمها الرسام اللي كان في الحمله
مع اسمه ديوز
وذكر مقاساته يبدو انه اخذ المقاس
فجاء بعدها الشيخ عبد الله ابن عبد العزيز
العنقري وهو كفيف لكنه مر بسدوس في طريقه
الى طلب العلم في الرياض
فذكروا له ان هنا بناء قديم وكذا تلمسته
بيدي الروايه رواها محمد الجاسر رحمهم
الله تلمس بيده وذكروا ان فيه حجاره ضخمه
باع او باعين البائع يعني مثل هالمقاس من
هنا الى اخر الاصبع وفيه كتابات قديمه
بقيت الى ولكن العنقري حدد لنا متى سقطت
يعني بالفتره ما بين
1306/13 في الغالب لم تكن العمود موجوده
فهي سقطت بين عام 81 و1306
ولكني قمت
بتصميم مجسم مقارب لها
وضعته في دوار في مدخل سادوس
نموذج لعمود سدس اذا هم قالوا من الجن
وقال الشاعر وقد كان ارباب الفصاحه كلما
راوا حسنا عدوهم من صنعه الجني
لولا لويس ما عرفنا اصلا لا عن القصر ولا
عن العمود ولا المقاسات لا الشكل ولا
المقاسات نعم
[موسيقى]
الحين اشوف هذا تقرير عام 89 ميلادي بمجله
اليمام انت مسويه كتبته عام 89 ميلادي عن
عمود سدوس وترجمت ما ذكره
عن العمود والرسمه اللي رسمها ديوز
وذكرت
العلماء المنازل والديار الذين تكلموا عن
سدوس او عن المبنى القديم طيب وفيه واحد
جاء اللي هو الالماني هانكو وكتب رساله
دكتوراه ضخمه عن البروفيسور جهود عظيمه
جدا في توثيق الحي القديم الطيني في سدوس
المسمى حي البلاد
اعد عنه رساله الدكتوراه
[موسيقى]
هذا التقرير عام 89 ميلادي عن العمود في
المجال الذي هذه الرسمه رسمها حمله لويس
بيلي ترجمتها في
كتبت عنها تقرير في مجله اليمامه طيب وين
رحاله اللي جو بعد لويس هانك البروفيسور
رساله الدكتوراه هذا ضخامته عن بلده سادوس
عن الحي القديم في سدوس حي البلاد رساله
دكتوراه فعلا رساله قيمه هو بحث قيم عن
القريه طيب من ناحيه معماريه هذا العمود
راينا له اشباه حول العالم
اعماريه لان نحن وجدنا اشياء كثيره في
الجزيره العربيه من ناحيه عماليه سابقه في
الحقيقه انا وجدت في جامعه الملك سعود
رساله باللغه الفرنسيه عن عمود مشابهه له
في حاله عمار في تبوك مقاربه له لكن لم
اجد مقارنه بين عمود سادوس وعمود حاله
عمار
يقول بيلي في كتابه رحله الى الرياض ان
سادوس بلد مزارعه صغيره وجميله ولطيفه
اجتمع بعضها مع بعضها الاخر في الوادي حول
حصن صغير منازل وجدران وحدائق سادوس انيقه
ومتصله يعمها السلام كل هذا هو ما جعلها
منطقه استقرار للانسان قبل الاسلام وبعده
حتى ذلك التاريخ الذي بداه فيها بني حنيفه
[موسيقى]